[Musique]
oh
louane hemera
mais tout le monde sait luan je prête ma
voix au personnage de violette dans les
indestructibles deux faits majeurs
thierry desroses je m'appelle thierry
desroses je prête ma voix frozo
l'équateur à mon avenir
si nous avons à lire mon vrai nom je
suis pas mandat lire je suis est né il
ya l'art et la manière
sommes très contents d'être là parce que
quatorze ans après je m'y attendais pas
et dans le rôle de monsieur
indestructible gérard norma le héros de
la famille indestructible composé par
élastique girl et trois enfants qui sont
quand même des enfants devaient garder
dans ce dans cet épisode je gère tout va
bien les indestructibles de c'est une
histoire de famille compliquée mais qui
va vous faire rire et ça ça le 4 juillet
dans tout procès
[Musique]